nous vous en parlions dès hier
l'annulation de l'american tour festival
cette année encore le grand rendez vous
des fans de culture américaine n'aura
pas lieu à cause de la crise sanitaire
on en parle ce soir avec christophe
caillaud jose directeur de l'événement
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
de nos studios de tours vous avez donc
été contraint d'annuler le festival à
cause de la crise dans quel état
d'esprit êtes-vous aujourd'hui
écoutez on est tous triste parce que ça
fait plus d'un an qu'on travaillait sur
ce projet ça déjà été annulés en 2020 on
est obligé pour des raisons techniques
et financières de l'annuler pour
l'édition de 2021 donc on est très
tristes voilà on est vraiment dans une
dans une époque de résilience
malheureusement pourquoi avoir décidé
d'annuler le festival alors que le
ministère de la culture va autoriser cet
été des événements qui ne dépasse pas je
crois les 5000 personnes je venais de
résumer le propos c'est à dire que notre
festival réunit plus de 65 mille
festivaliers payant sur trois jours si
vous voulez et l'économie même de notre
festival passe par des exposants de la
restauration des buvettes qui sont
interdites aujourd'hui par par le
ministère donc s'ils voulaient
l'équation entre accueillir 5000
personnes
on aurait bien aimé mais l'équation
budgétaire et l'identité même du
festival
le fait de se rencontrer si vous voulez
on n'est pas capable de le tenir un
soixante cinq mille 5000 effectivement
65 mille visiteurs c'est beaucoup d'eux
édition n'auront donc pas lieu 2020 et
2021 avec quelles conséquences concrètes
économique pour vous alors pour nous si
vous voulez en fait il fallait qu'on
prenne vite la décision parce que
c'était voilà dans quinze jours on
allait déclencher l'ensemble du
processus notamment l'achat de
d'affichage pour la communication les
lancements de billetterie etc
donc il fallait vraiment prendre des
décisions maintenant avant de rentrer
dans une spirale de coups que l'on
n'aurait pas pu maîtriser et qui nous
emmenait vers une catastrophe économique
donc là si vous voulez on on limite la
catastrophe on est tous très tristes
bien évidemment moi je pense surtout à
tulle et tout l'écosystème qui vivaient
autour de cet american tour festival
parce que pour recevoir 65 mille
festivaliers
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voient là et
c'est de les nourrir d'apporter un
simple de deux stands avec des vêtements
etc bref tout est une économie en fait
les hôteliers auquel je pense beaucoup
ce soir cela n'aura pas lieu donc la
conséquence y aller elle est importante
justement un écosystème que vous disent
les habitués du festival qui ne pourront
pas encore une fois venir cette année
quelle est leur réaction alors leurs
réactions elles sont vraiment on est
vraiment très soutenu par l'ensemble de
nos festivaliers tous les petits mots
que l'on reçoit aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment pour assurer les organisateurs
du festival de leur soutien ils ont bien
compris
c'était pas notre faute qu'on avait fait
tout ce qu'il fallait pour pour y
arriver
donc c'est vraiment une forme de soutien
et vraiment je les remercier parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'affection dans tous ces
petits mots que l'on que l'on reçoit
rendez vous donc on l'espère en 2022
merci 2022 2022 au grand rendez vous est
pris on l'espère merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce soir